اتفق معه ويتمم هذا الحديث الحقيقه اذا
كان نظر الدكتور ايضا الى هؤلاء الشعراء
واعطانا ايضا بعض اخبارهم وهناك ايضا
شعراء كثيرين جدا غير هؤلاء لكن بالمقابل
اذا كانت هذه الفئه من الشعراء لفتوا هذا
الانتباه عفوا فان هناك ايضا فئه اخرى
الذين هم العلماء وطلاب العلم لفتوا ايضا
الى هذا الامر ولهذا نجد ايضا العلماء منذ
ايام العالم الكبير المشهور احمد بن عطوه
الذي توفي سنه 1948 كان علماء من علماء
العارض وايضا استقروا في الدرعيه في فتره
من الفترات وايضا كان له يعني احكام وايضا
احكام شرعيه هناك فانتقل الى الشام فكان
يذكر لي ايضا علماء الشام في تلك الفتره
واقع الحاله الامنيه في هذه المنطقه وما
هي الاحكام التي ستطبق وكذلك ايضا لدينا
فتوى مشهوره يعني اذا كان نظرنا في هذا
الجانب الامني هناك فتوى مشهوره لعالم
رياض الشيخ عبد الله بن محمد بن الدهلان
كانت الشيخ عبد الله بن محمد ابن دلال
توفي تقريبا في عام
في ذي الحجه قبل دوله وايضا قبل قيام
الدوله وايضا لكن كان تاثيره هو المجدد
ايضا الثاني او الثالث العلماء الحنابله
في هذه المنطقه فكان تعرض عليه القضايا
ايضا الامنيه يعني اذا كان تعرض عليه
القضايا الامنيه في كتاب مشهور اسمه
الفواكه العديده في المسائل المفيده للشيخ
احمد بن منقور الذي توفي في سنه 1125 فحمل
هذا الكتاب اسئله وعجائب وغرائب وفرائد
ايضا للحاله الواقعه في هذه المنطقه مثلا
يشير ايضا هذا العالم يسالونه الناس
يقولون ما رايك يا شيخ كيف يستطيع الناس
الحج ونحن لا نستطيع الامن فهل يجوز ايضا
ان نستاجر اناس يحمون ايضا مسيرتنا لهذا
الاتجاه فقال الشيخ نعم
يجوز لكم ذلك وهؤلاء يسمون الرفق الرفق
يعني يرافقه في الطريق فيدفع عليه مبلغ
الحمايه هؤلاء يدفع عليهم مبلغ الحمايه
يتجهون الى بعض المقدسه هناك ايضا الشيخ
عبد الله بن محمد بن دلال له فتوى ايضا
كان الشيء ابن غشام شاعر الامور توفي
تقريبا قتل سنه 1970 فكان الشيخ ايضا
نعم فكان ايضا هناك اشكالات فكانوا يسالون
الشيخ يقول من ينفذ هذه الاحكام وينشر
العدل فيقول الشيخ انا افديكم بجواز قتله
لان لا احد الحقيقه يستطيع تنفيذ مثل هذه
الاحكام فالناحيه الامنيه كانت الحقيقيه
لا احد يعني هو بوصفه عالم او رجل دين
يعتقد ان هذا الرجل او الامير في هذه
القريه انه ظالم ويظلم الناس سيقول لكن لا
يوجد سلطه مركزيه تنفذ هذا الامر لا اشك
في قتله رميزان يعني لا
اشكاليه كان ما كان هناك قوه وسلطه سياسيه
تجبرها هؤلاء على ايضا الامن والامان
الذين يعني الذي يتطلبوا هذا المجتمع
ولهذا لدينا القاعده الاساسيه في قيام
الدوله والعنصر الكبير انه الجانب الامني
هو اعظم عامل لقيام الدوله لانه الناس
اذكر لبعض الاخوه يقولون ربما تجاوزت
الجانب الديني او الجانب ايضا الدعوي نقول
لهم نحن نفقد الجانب الامني ولم نفقد
الدين الدين منذ وصول هذه الرساله
المحمديه صلى الله عليه وسلم ايضا الى هذه
المنطقه انتشرت واصبح الناس ايضا في
الاسلام ومطبقين للتعاليم والاركان فكيف
تقول لي انه جدد الدين انا اقول الدين
موجود ثابت